[Musique]
puis mois d'emprisonnement avec sursis
et 25000 euros damende requis contre
serge martin l'ancien préfet des
yvelines comparaissait ce lundi 7
décembre devant le tribunal de
versailles
accusé de détournement de fonds faux et
usage de faux il avait déjà reconnu les
faits l'entreprise spécialisée dans les
services informatiques atos dans la
tourmente
sept cas de cancer rare du cerveau ont
été détectés parmi les salariés et
anciens salariés de la multinationale
situé aux clayes-sous-bois l' enquête
est en cours pour déterminer si elle est
responsable ou non le tronçon aérien de
la ligne 18 a été modifié sur le plateau
de saclay ce métro doit relier
l'aéroport d'orly à versailles à
l'horizon 2030
la société du grand paris après la
décision de construire une partie du
gain du gros saule entre saclay et man
il ya un bouton stop sans contact c'est
la nouveauté abordé ski bus
ce nouveau système innovant mis en place
dans cinq véhicules du réseau est en
expérimentation pendant deux mois une
pièce de théâtre saint-quentinoise
c'est le projet de j'habite hashtag
saint quentin en yvelines les habitants
de cinq des douze communes ont été
choisies comme comédien représentation
le 13 février prochain au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est la bonne nouvelle de la semaine
pour le sport amateur en extérieur après
les plus jeunes la semaine dernière les
seniors ont repris les entraînement sans
contact
en attendant le retour espéré des
compétitions au mois de janvier
[Musique]